we aim to provide you with a career
advisor that does all of those things
the career adviser gets to know you
understands what you want from a career
perspective helps you discover roles
that you may not have been aware of we
make the apply process as frictionless
as possible we Advocate on your behalf
to employers before you even apply we
will put your profile in front of
employers that we think you're a great
fit for and encourage them to invite you
to apply to that job we'll also keep you
informed throughout the process we will
you know hey this employer has looked at
your resume this employer has given you
a thumbs up we give you a sense of
progress and so you know where you
[Music]
stand costume safy welcome to 20-minute
leaders and welcome to Israel how are
you I'm doing great thank you for having
me Michael I'm I'm looking forward to
the conversation thank you very very
much for being here kasim H the Chief
Operating Officer of zi
recruiter H it's quite a special
occasion
um because um you know leadership comes
in different shapes and sizes and so do
entrepreneurs and and different leaders
in such organization zipper cter is a is
a pretty foundational company in today's
world um with and with more than a
thousand people and an amazing amazing
team very proud to have um our own R&D
here in Israel you know I'm really
curious as to both your own Journey with
the incredible experiences that we we
just read to the audience H that they
just heard you know I'm curious to hear
about what it means to be the Chief
Operating Officer of such a company what
zip recuiter is all about and how does
this whole thing play into kasim's a you
know Journey your own personal Journey
so I'd love to get started and I want
you to take me back all the way to 2000
you know Walt Disney Company you're a
senior analyst and and I want to connect
the dogs your journey to where you are
and where you are now so help me do that
a little bit yeah it's it's a it's a bit
of a Meandering Journey so so bear with
me as we go through it but uh you know I
started my career at the Walt Disney
Company as you as you noted and um I had
a what I would regard as a relatively
unique and uh interesting opportunity
there so I joined the strategic planning
group there which you can think of as
sort of the internal consultants and
bankers uh for the company and so that's
sort of you know a traditional role you
know for for for folks but what really
excited me was um I joined ort of a a
small team within strap planning that
was really focused on building new
businesses leveraging the institutional
knowledge and capital of the Walt Disney
Company so rather than sort of you know
initially being assigned to uh partner
with an existing business unit and sort
of guide them through their strategic
planning thinking through opportunities
you know that was again the traditional
path for someone in strp planning what I
spent my town doing was really building
new businesses uh that leveraged again
the company's assets and so so um I I
got to work on a couple of very very
interesting projects uh that were really
around you know a bit ahead of their
time they were really around content
distribution um you know we we think
about streaming and everything today and
that's sort of secondhand but uh for for
us back in 2000 the idea of Distributing
so and that at that time you know Disney
content from you know direct to
Consumers was a was a novel idea and so
um you know I worked on movies.com and
moviebeam which were again two
initiatives as the names suggest that
were really around um sending Disney and
other Studio content to uh to Consumers
directly and so that was really the
appeal of of um that opportunity was to
to be an entrepreneur or an entrepreneur
frankly to to build new businesses again
within the a company that's got a
tremendous amount of resources and so
did that for three years um which was
which was fantastic uh and then sort of
you know move moved on from there and um
and and happy to explore that to ex
that's interesting as well I mean you
you had um you know trans transition to
to consultancy and you know a leading
and then a leading search engine for
that time Yahoo openx cop and and
obviously Zipperer if you're looking at
and and I do want to me you know delay
on on Ponder on Zipperer for for a long
time so if you're looking at the
different things that you've done and
with the different positions and the
different types of roles and types of
organizations youve you been with where
how did you situate yourself in terms of
your growth trajectory how did what did
you learn about yourself as you were
going through these different stations
sort of what your your role in this
ecosystem or your leadership role in
this Tech world yeah so I think there's
a couple couple things that you know
that I've learned over the course of the
last you know 15 20 years and you know
um as you mentioned sort I spent you
know several years at Yahoo from there I
went to openex which was one of the
first programmatic ad exchanges and then
from there jump to scopely and then have
have been at cutter since and I think
you'll see sort of the common through
line uh over the last 15 years has
really been a focus on
marketplaces uh you know at Yahoo I I uh
worked on business operations for their
advertising businesses which were
marketplaces the search Marketplace the
display Marketplace uh an exchange a
company we bought right media openx was
a Marketplace uh at scopely I sort of
had an opportunity to to not run AET
Marketplace but actually be a
participant so running publishing there
you know I was responsible for for user
acquisition marketing uh distribution
and the advertising side of the business
as well and so you know we I was a
participant in other marketplaces to
acquire users I was a participating as a
publisher selling in marketplaces so it
gave me a bit of a different Vantage
Point um and obviously zip recruiter we
are a two-sided Marketplace that connect
job Seekers and employers today so I am
fascinated by marketplaces
uh frankly I don't think that there's
another business model that creates as
much value in the world as marketplaces
and so uh from a value creation point of
view I think it's it's just phenomenal
um they're also complicated
intellectually interesting fascinating
very challenging problems and so um the
combination of of those two things
really sort of drives and has driven my
journey over the last you know 15 years
so you were talking about sort of the
the the passion you have for the
complexity and opportunity of
marketplaces let's let's let's dive into
that just a little bit so obviously you
know some of the biggest Platforms in
the world that have changed the way we
are interacting are marketplaces right
Amazon Airbnb Facebook zip recruiter so
many of these and and I just mentioned a
few eBay of course there's so much
potential why what is sort of the the
you know if you had to distill why it's
so inter
what really is it what is it about this
multiplayer negotiation system that
makes it such a unique and a big
opportunity yeah I think frankly it it
goes back to the value creation
component um the ability to connect
buyers and sellers whether as you noted
whether it's through Amazon whether it's
through Uber whether it's through a swap
meet I just think there's there's no
other mechanism that creates as much
value in the world as connecting to
entities and so that is ultimately what
marketplaces do now now the way you do
that is actually you know not not often
as straightforward as that so it sounds
simple in theory but you know there's
sort of four key components that I think
about when I think about any Marketplace
that any Marketplace has to do so the
first is they have to drive
participation what does that mean you
have to bring buyers and sellers into
the marketplace and you can do that
through marketing through sales through
BD but frankly you have to do that
through having a a great product that
naturally attracts both buyers and
sellers and so that's step number one
step number two is uh is matching how do
you get the right buyer in front of the
right seller how do you understand
preferences opportunity costs budgets
and um how do you get those signals and
incorporate those signals to put the
right buyer in front of the right seller
and and you know that is um an
incredibly challenging thing to do and
there's there's really two components to
that frankly one is how do we think
about surfacing the right buyer to the
right seller so let's go back to
um eBay as an example of a Marketplace
uh you know if you wanted to buy a chair
on eBay as a buyer you'd go to eBay and
do a search and uh you'd see a chair
great eBay's done the first part of
matching which is surfacing all of the
potential Supply and and matching it to
the demand there's a second component
which is now you have to actually clear
the transaction you have to decide who's
going to win the chair if they're
conducting an auction and so you know
there's mechanisms by which you do that
as well but ultimately the goal is like
there there is a reason that a
Marketplace exists in the world for
example the reason zip recruiter exist
in the world is to help people find
their next great opportunity ultimately
we exist to drive hes there's a reason
that Uber exists in the world it's to
get people from A to B and so matching
is ultimately how you clear that
transaction and how you actually
complete the value you create in the
world the third thing I think about is
pricing
how much are you going to charge the
buyer how much are you going to give to
the seller how much are you going to
keep for running the marketplace and um
I think many marketplaces to be honest
with you spend an inordinate amount of
time on pricing and the reason I say
that is because I think about value
creation and value extraction and so
value creation is again how much value
are we creating in the world value
extraction is how much of that value
that we create are we able to keep and
for me pricing is primarily about
dividing up the value we create in the
world into its constituent so um it's
really a zero sum gain frankly all it
does is divide the value between the
buyer the seller and the marketplace
operator don't get me wrong super
important and you got to run a business
and it's it's it's um it's something you
have to think about but I'm far more
focused on value
creation than value extraction generally
and I sort of take it on faith that if
we create more value we'll figure out a
way to extract our fair share of that
value so that's the third component and
then the fourth fourth component is
really um feedback how do you get
feedback from participants in the
marketplace that helps primarily inform
future participation and matching so um
can give you an example uh you know in
IN Zip recruiter so zip recruiter you
know uh employers we job Seekers apply
to jobs employers then engage with those
job Seekers they rate them they say hey
this is a great candidate this is a
candidate that may not match may not be
a great fit and they give that feedback
to zip recruiter we do two things with
that first we share that feedback with
the job Seeker to keep them informed
that's valuable but equally important we
leverage that feedback to improve our
matching to directly influence the the
future candidat that that employer gets
so that feedback is really again a mean
to an end it's a means to informing
future participation in matching you
think of the same thing is true when you
know in in situation of uber where you
rate the buyer rate the driver and the
and the rider all of those things inform
future matching and so those are the
four key components that I think any
Marketplace has to perform participation
matching pricing and feedback and
obviously underneath that you need a
platform that operates you have customer
support you have to have uptime you have
all those things but but those are the
four fundamental tenants of any
Marketplace as sort of as I see it so if
we're looking for the early days of the
and I'm going back to the year 2000 for
strategic planning and sort of from an
analyst perspective you you want to get
started you realize there's a mark you
realize there's an opportunity for a
Marketplace there's there's multi
multiple players that are going to be
benefiting from some exchange or some
some sort of middle ground or platform
that serves them how and then you
mentioned a lot of the different
decision-making points that you have to
figure out such as pricing for example
or feedback how do you get started what
are sort what is sort of your preferred
way of thinking about just initially
laying out a foundational strategy for
how this Marketplace looks you know do
you is it a you know through focus
groups do you just get started and just
you know Tinker with it AB test what
what is sort of the Holy Grail of of
getting to the right optimization there
yeah and look I think this starts with
you know um some very fundamental
product thinking that you know is
certainly applicable to marketplaces but
frankly is more broadly applicable which
is you need to find where there are
unmet needs of
customers and that is the heart of of
any business of any product of any
offering and you know the only way
you're going to do that is by talking to
people talking to potential customers
and really becoming intimate with what
their unmet needs are and developing
empathy and once identified what the
unmet needs of of your customer base are
now you have a couple decisions to make
one
um are are those unmet needs so profound
that solving them will actually create a
ton of value and that's step one find a
set of unmet needs that really if you
can solve them are going to be valuable
step two is identifying solutions to
those unmet needs and so that's sort of
like the the generic steps that I think
about and if you sort of want to apply
them to zip recruiter um I think if if
you think about Job Seekers um and what
their unmet needs are I think they're
they're multifold but uh at at the core
of it I think the job search process is
generally
broken uh if you ask job Seekers that's
what they'll tell you and to get more
specific um you know they'll tell you
wow I have a difficult time discovering
jobs that I think could be a great fit
yeah and then once I discover a job it's
very tedious and repetitive to apply to
those jobs I have to keep entering the
same information again and again and
again they'll also tell you hey I have
nobody advocating on my behalf you know
I have to hope that the the hiring
manager sees my resume and wants to talk
to me but I have no way to advocate for
myself or no one advocating for me
they'll also tell you one of the biggest
complaints is uh you know I apply to a
job and then I hear nothing back yeah it
goes into a the black hole problem and I
don't know whether they haven't even
looked at my application I don't know
whether they think you know they're
still deciding whether I'm a fit or not
or they decided I'm not a fit and they
just haven't told me and so for all of
those reasons uh job Seekers you know
there's a very visceral feeling amongst
the job Seeker population that the
process is broken that unmet need is
very real and frankly I don't think that
anybody has definitively addressed that
and so that is aim to do at zior we aim
to provide you with a career advisor
that does all of those things the career
adviser gets to know you understands
what you want from a career perspective
helps you discover roles that you you
know you may not have been aware of we
make the apply process as frictionless
as possible we Advocate on your behalf
to employers before you even apply we
will put your profile in front of
employers that we think you're a great
fit for and encourage them to invite you
to apply to that job we'll also keep you
informed throughout the process we will
let you know hey this uh employer has
looked at your resume this employer has
given you a thumbs up this employer has
looked at your resume mult multiple
times and so we give you a sense of
progress and so you know where you stand
and so those are sort of you sort of
ideas sort of how we think about
identifying what the unmit needs are and
you go back to how we did that we did
that by talking to job Seekers and
that's the only way you're actually
going to get that information and so we
talk to hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of job Seekers and sort of try
to find patterns it's about pattern
recognition and so through that research
we identified these set of unmet needs
and then embarked upon Building
Solutions so that we we believe address
them I love that well where is cassim in
all this in this whole world what what
is your or your world within this large
world I I think I have the the the best
role company to be honest with you um
and you know I know the role of coo
means lots of different things at lots
of different companies um but at zioc or
at least uh what it means is that I get
to look after the operating teams and so
um I have the the good forun of getting
to work uh with the sales team the
marketing team the product team the tech
team the analytics team um to help build
this Vision to help build the products
that fulfill our mission connecting
people to their their next grade
opportunity and so for me um I think
uh the reason I love my role so much is
because um I get to connect all the dots
and so you know you go back to sort of
you know my journey one of the things
that I've come to to realize is I'm uh I
think most fulfilled and also most
effective when I'm able to oversee and
engage with multiple disciplines so I
don't like to be as Specialized or as
focused on a particular you know uh area
I'm I'm happy to do that and go deep and
and uh and develop you know intuition
and understanding but for me my my
ability to wrap my arms around the
totality of the business is what really
uh invigorates me and gets me going and
so being able to sort of see sales and
marketing and sort of connect that to
what their needs are to to the product
and how we build what we build and then
take those products to Market and sort
of you know I think that uh it's it's a
rare opportunity for someone to be able
to be involved across all of those those
disciplines um and and so that's what
what what I get to spend my day doing it
also means that there is no you know
sort of typical traditional day for for
me as a COO because I have to move from
thinking about sales to thinking about
product thinking about the tech team
thinking about how we sort of you know
from from a data perspective and you
know for some folks that may feel like a
lot of switching and you know there
switching costs and and that's that's
that's difficult um to to endure but for
me
I actually uh I derive energy and and
Joy from that because again it allows me
to make connections between what we're
doing across the different functions um
and so so that's how I think about what
my role is and and um and what I get to
do incredible cassim thank you so much
this was so enjoyable and awesome and
going to keep on cheering from the side
and uh being a fan of of the work that
you do so thank you very very much and
then best of luck with making a positive
impact everywhere you go thank you thank
you so much for having me and and uh
I'll look forward to the next
conversation I appreciate it